Is "Gran Turismo" a green light for other
Playstation game adaptations? Here's a
breakdown of the film's high-octane final lap
and what it could mean for a possible franchise.
Before we race to the film's finale, let's recap
the biggest moments leading up to it. After Nissan
executive Danny Moore gets approval to create
the competition series "GT Academy" and recruits
bitterly retired racer Jack Salter, he starts
to pick out competitors from across the globe.
British hopeful Jann Mardenborough joins the
competition after earning his spot in a virtual
qualifying race. Although Jann and his fellow
competitors are hopeful that their dreams will
become a reality, Salter gives them a reality
check through some harsh but necessary training.
Despite Salter's tough training methods that push
everyone to their limits, Jann is not only able
to improve his skills but ultimately comes
out victorious by the narrowest of margins.
Before being able to join the ranks
of the world's top racers though,
Jann must earn his professional license and
contract with Nissan by placing fourth or higher
in a qualifying series. Although Jann's first
race doesn't go well, he steadily improves and
is eventually able to place high enough to earn
his license and start his professional career.
Shortly after signing his contract with Nissan,
Jann enters his first race and even though
things start well, it ends in disaster.
Jann's car unexpectedly flips in the air
and crashes into a spectator section
-- accidentally killing a spectator.
This tragedy causes Jann to blame himself for
what happened and give up racing altogether.
Although Salter has his doubts about
Jann and his fellow competitors' ability
to actually compete in motorsport, he
slowly starts to see how capable they
are -- especially Jann. By the time
Jann earns his professional license,
Salter completely believes in him and
is arguably his biggest supporter.
"I'm not afraid."
"You should be."
After Jann's accident though, Salter
is crushed by Jann's decision to quit
racing. Salter ultimately decides to reach out
to Jann and take him for a drive back to where
the accident occurred. There, he finally
tells Jann what caused him to stop racing,
and it turns out that it's similar
to what Jann is going through.
Salter was also a part of a tragic accident
at the peak of his career -- which caused a
fatality that he was never able to shake.
Like Jann, even though people told Salter
that it wasn't his fault, he was never able to
fully let it go and it caused him to struggle to
get back into the driver's seat. To this day,
Salter still regrets it and doesn't want to
see Jann go down the same path. Salter's
story ends up inspiring Jann to not only
reignite his racing career but also achieve
the dreams that were cut short for Salter.
Although Jann is ready to return to racing,
Danny gives him some unfortunate news. While
Jann isn't seen as responsible for the
accident, others would rather have him
no longer race. Most of the other drivers
have signed a petition to keep "simulation
racers" like Jann from competing -- causing
some of Jann's sponsors to consider pulling
their support. With Jann not wanting to quit,
he comes up with a way for them to prove that
he belongs -- by placing on the podium at the 24
Hours of Le Mans with a team of simulation racers.
Salter and Danny agree with Jann and call for
two of his "GT Academy" adversaries to race
alongside him in a three-man team. Before the race
starts, Jann is also able to reconcile with his
father -- gaining the support and acceptance
he's yearned for. Jann struggles early in the
race after witnessing another driver crash, but
with the help of Salter reminding Jann of what
he's driving for, he's able to get in the right
headspace. Despite some issues with the pit crew,
Jann is able to fight back in the race and
ultimately lead his team to a third place
finish -- cementing their place in history and
squashing any doubt of their ability to perform.
Shortly after Jann and his team celebrate
on the podium, the film delivers some small
tidbits about Jann's real-life career and
involvement with the film. Alongside some
photos of Jann's real experience competing
in "GT Academy" and driving professionally,
the film acknowledges that Jann has competed
in over 200 races and earned many achievements
in his career. As an added bonus, the film
even tells viewers that Jann actually acts
as the stunt double for actor Archie Madekwe
in the film. However, the bigger question is:
How much of what we see in the film
is true to Jann's real-life story?
While certain characters like Jack
Salter are solely made up for the film,
the events of the story are pretty accurate --
but somewhat told out of order. For instance,
the catastrophic accident that caused Jann
to crash into a field of spectators actually
happened a couple of years after he placed
third at Le Mans. Also, he didn't race alongside
other "GT Academy" graduates at Le Mans — he
raced with them at the Spa 24 hours instead.
"I've been cynical as well, because
you have kids sitting in front of
TV screens playing motor circuit
games, or whatever you call them."
So even though Jann's story in the film
is inspired by actual events in Jann's
career rather than wholeheartedly based on
them, "Gran Turismo" does its best to pay
tribute to the achievements and impact
Jann has had on the motorsport world.
One of the biggest debates throughout the film
is whether simulation players
can hack it on a real track.
"Much easier with a joystick, isn't it? Ha ha ha."
That question is what drives Danny to
create "GT Academy" and causes Salter
to openly doubt all the participants at
the start of the competition. Jann is at
the center of this debate as well. He's
trying to prove his critics wrong and
show that the "Gran Turismo" community should
be taken seriously. There are major hurdles
for Jann and other "GT Academy" competitors,
but he eventually puts his doubters in check.
When Jann enters the world of professional
racing, he's quite a force to be reckoned
with. He continually improves his craft
and impresses people in his first race,
even though it doesn't end in victory. Jann is
living proof that simulation and video game skills
can translate to reality and be a stepping stone
for someone wanting to be involved in the real
thing. Moments including Jann knowing parts of the
car Salter didn't expect him to and understanding
how to make passes on turns are great
instances of the game connecting with reality.
"That was actually pretty great."
The film further gives the "Gran Turismo"
community, and really every sim community,
a voice and shows that they are very capable
of turning their virtual passions into reality.
As much as "Gran Turismo" is a positive message
about chasing your dreams, it's also a bit of a
cautionary tale. Sure, there's a lot of
heartwarming success in Jann's journey,
but it doesn't overshadow how the film highlights
the dangers of motorsport. Before Jann even starts
his "GT Academy" journey, Salter makes it
clear that students could potentially die
if things go wrong. He even says that there
would be no shame in quitting and that he
wouldn't let anyone he didn't believe in sit
in the driver's seat. At first, this seems
like an intimidation tactic from Salter, but
it quickly becomes clear that he's not wrong.
The crashes in "Gran Turismo" prove how
vicious and genuinely deadly motorsport
can be. One wrong twitch during a turn or
slight hesitation can lead to the driver's
death and the deaths of other drivers and
spectators. Jann experiences this multiple
times throughout the film. He sees a fiery crash
at Le Mans that the driver miraculously survives,
and he himself is involved in a crash
that accidentally kills a spectator.
Even the psychological trauma drivers
can suffer from is just as horrifying.
"Gran Turismo" doesn't shy away from the
danger and potential tragedy of motorsport.
At its core, "Gran Turismo" is a sports underdog
story meant not only to warm viewers' hearts but
also to inspire them to pursue their passions.
Like any underdog, Jann faces his fair share of
adversity. From his father disapproving
of his aspirations, becoming a racer,
and Salter doubting his ability throughout his
time at "GT Academy," there wasn't much support
for Jann. Plus he has to face and ultimately beat
his "GT Academy" competitors, who were equally as
talented. Even when he finally earns his chance
to race in professional circuits, he's looked
down upon by other drivers and is forced to deal
with an accident that was beyond his control.
Yet, Jann constantly perseveres and overcomes
the obstacles in front of him through his sheer
determination. He always finds ways to push beyond
his limits and impress anyone who doubts him. His
father and Salter are certainly impressed
by his drive and ultimately become his most
pivotal supporters. It's what makes Jann leading
a landmark performance at Le Mans so meaningful:
Audiences have been with him every step
of the way. "Gran Turismo" is a classic
sports story with underdog vibes that remind
viewers that everyone's dreams can come true
no matter how big or small. Buy more video
games, and you too could become world famous.
The film ending on Jann Mardenborough's
legendary performance at the 24 Hours of
Le Mans actually holds more meaning than
you'd think. At the start of the film,
Jann is racing his friend online in
"Gran Turismo" on the Le Mans track.
"I know this track."
So competing in the real-life endurance
race in the finale brings his journey full
circle. Jann and his team placing third at
Le Mans is arguably one of his most notable
achievements in his real-life professional
career. It was the race that really put him
on the map and helped him break away from
being looked at as the "GT Academy" winner.
Le Mans being the setting for the film's
finale is also meaningful for fans of the
sport and general fans since the race has an
iconic legacy in the sport. The 24 Hours of Le
Mans is easily one of the most well-known
and highly-regarded events in the racing
world. As explained in the film, placing there
solidifies you as a legend in the sport. So,
it's a setting that elevates
the meaning behind Jann and his
team trying to get "sim racers" like
themselves the respect they deserve.
So often these days, when
a big name movie premieres,
audiences wonder if it has franchise potential.
At this point, Sony hasn't made any announcements
regarding a sequel to "Gran Turismo," and
honestly there probably won't be one. The
movie is based on the real-life story of Jann
Mardenborough, and not strictly on the game.
Though a sequel could focus on Jann's career
after his origin story, that seems unlikely.
Another potential could be a movie that focuses
on another driver with a similar background.
Even more interesting could be a follow-up
that is completely original and not based
on an actual racing figure. But the fact
that "Gran Turismo" is a biopic makes it
unique in the world of video game movie
adaptations, so a fictionalized follow-up
probably doesn't make sense for a potential
sequel. However, if Sony's new movie does
well at the box office you can expect that
at least one executive will look for ways to
bring the "Gran Turismo" name back to the
screen for another lap around the track.
Although Sony and PlayStation have shown
interest in turning their movie and TV
adaptations of video games into successful
franchises, the ending of "Gran Turismo" says
something different. While we already know that
a second season of "The Last of Us" is coming
and that the endings of "Uncharted" and
"Twisted Metal" hint at potential futures,
"Gran Turismo" is an adaptation that feels
complete. The ending highlights Jann's success
in the film and in real-life and doesn't
suggest that there's another story to tell.
Since it seems like Sony isn't trying to
establish a big cinematic future for "Gran
Turismo," it suggests that we could see smaller
adaptations in the future. PlayStation games
like "Concrete Genie," "Ape Escape," "Shadow of
the Colossus," or maybe even "Patapon" could get
big or small screen adaptations one day. Prior
to "Gran Turismo," we expected that PlayStation
would try to turn all of their adaptations into
robust franchises. But "Gran Turismo" changes
that narrative with its ending and opens
the door for more potential adaptations.